you're going to look back and and this
could be the most powerful and valuable
work you've ever done because this is
really when people talk about the
internal game they want to change
behaviors they want to change results in
their life but where it starts is with
our thinking so it's our thoughts that
turn to our emotions turn to our
behaviors turn to our results you know
the brain is is the thing that what
science has shown over years you can
actually shape in mold you can rewire
some of the patterns so uh we're going
to create this new state of being for
you to go out there in the world we want
to take the great work that you've done
we're going to go over it we're going to
put it in some kind of form and then
that's where you're going to begin to
leave this conversation with a practice
that is going to work on the
neuroplasticity of your brain of really
rewiring uh the patterns that you set up
for all these years you may have to
change the name of the show to why I
suck cuz after this work there there
won't be no more you suck it's like how
can I be
greater
all right believe Nation back for round
three with mindset coach to the Stars
Devin banderson this is the trilogy
episode so he gave me some homework I
did it right away idea to action and
after the homework uh he said let's hop
on another call to go next step so here
we are uh in episode two we went over a
lot of my low grade thoughts and he gave
me this exercise to flip through them
and do a board of directors and imagine
Evan at 43 33 23 13 and 7 and uh forgive
myself for those thoughts and uh anyway
and then then what would a more powerful
thought be and I went through all that
and now we're here so I I I gave him my
homework and now he's gonna tear into me
again and tell me why I suck and here we
go round three we've Now by round three
there's no more you suck that that
that's an old thought that we've gotten
gotten rid of thank you for
noticing you got got it brother so so I
want to acknowledge you for for doing
the work you are the epitome of event
action you know you get put up to do
something and you get right in action
and you sent it to me um so today it is
the trilogy this is where it all comes
together right we want to take the great
work that you've done we're going to go
over it we're going to put it in some
kind of form and then that's where
you're going to begin to leave this um
conversation with a practice that is
going to work on you know the
neuroplasticity of your brain of really
rewiring uh the patterns that you set up
for all these years and one of the
patterns you may have to change the name
of the show to why I suck because after
this after this work there there won't
be no more you suck it's like how can I
be greater so um but but I want to
acknowledge you and before we jump in
and and pull your work out because I
know you did a video of of what you
wrote but I'd like you to share it with
me um what was that process like for you
okay so gu you know the recap for
somebody who's just joining live now uh
on episode one uh he had me list through
all my low grade thoughts and I went to
a a sauna torture session and sat down
and put myself through hell and think of
all the potential low great thoughts and
things like I'm not growing fast enough
not making up an impact and we I filled
out this list and it's kind of wet
because I sweat it all over it round two
was to forgive myself for each of those
things and and talk to younger me some
of them took longer than others uh I
didn't try to rush it you know trying to
actually think who was I at 33 and who
was I at 23 and who was I at 13 and who
was I at seven and like trying to pick a
moment that I can connect back to um
some of them
were impactful uh some of them were like
sevene 11 saying like dude what are you
talking about irrelevant right right
right exactly it's like you you're not
you're not making enough of an impact
for what I'm seven but but you know it's
part of the uh part of the exercise so
so it was fun um what was great was
seeing some of the repeated some of the
answers that came back so uh at the end
of each exercise was then okay and the
new truth is and then you know what is
the truth that comes back and there were
some similar answers on some of them um
which is great now that's kind of the
consistent reminder that I need on
ongoing and yeah it um thank you for the
exercise and it was a blessing to go
through there was some homework I had to
do like I find a Tupac quote and I had
to do a couple other things and I did
that kind of was in the moment bubble
gum this one I wanted to uh I think we
recorded on a Friday and so I did it on
the weekend to just make sure there was
nothing else I had to get to and no
other commitments nothing else kind of
buzzing in my head so I can dedicate the
appropriate time and mind space to be to
do it properly instead of just saying
you know I got it done check but you
know didn't actually put intention to it
so I did that and yeah powerful grateful
to go through it and now ready to see uh
what happens next well let's create the
magic next and and I would I acknowledge
you also Evan for putting the time and
not rushing through it because in many
ways you know you you're going to look
back and and this could be the most
powerful and valuable work you've ever
done right because this is really when
people talk about the internal game
right they thought they're talking about
you know they want to change behaviors
they want to change results in their
life but where it starts is with our
thinking so it's our thoughts that turn
to our emotions turn to our behaviors T
turn to our results so the fact that
you're really becoming conscious and
aware of the inner game and and
understand that you actually you know
the brain is is the thing that what
science has shown over years you can
actually shape and mold you can rewire
some of the patterns so uh we're going
to create this new state of being for
you to go out there in the world
remember when we first started we were
like if we want to get to 35 million
subscribers my first question wasn't
like let's get a strategy what do we
need to do my first question was who do
you need to be and so this work that
we've done over the last couple sessions
has been kind of the trilogy to creating
a way of being for you to be the guy who
has 35 million subscribers not because
of the number because of the impact that
you want to make on the world okay so
let's pull out the homework and why
don't you just read all I want you to do
is read the new thoughts the the
upgraded thoughts and I may pause you I
may give you a suggestion or two if I
see something there and and one of the
suggestions is there may be a couple
opportunities to put an i statement and
the reason why I like an I am statement
um in in some of it not every one of
them but because vibrationally that's
two of the most powerful or from my
experience two they're the two most
powerful words in the world because it's
like I am and now you're creating a way
of being so sometimes people share how
they feel and they make it who they're
being meaning for instance they may feel
tired right but people often you ask
them how you doing I'm tired I am tired
and then you look at them and they they
go ahead and have a tired existence M
right right or I am overwhelmed and then
you look at them and they are being
overwhelmed so what we want to do is we
want to put the correct vibrational
connection to to these new Declarations
of who you're being so there may be
opportunities for that and uh so just
read them uh one at a time and then I
may pause you and and we can go from
there okay I have a I have an extra
confession go
ahead uh I was inspired by your
Declaration of Independence yeah so uh I
didn't want to leave that uh that energy
while it was still there and just let it
like pass so yeah I ended up taking a
lot of this stuff and pouring it into my
own Declaration of Independence don't
know if that was going to be part of the
homework or not I turned most of what
was on here into I believe statements
instead of I am statements so we can
look at that too potenti if you want to
see what the I believe statements are
but I'm also happy to change the whole
so you may have jumped One Step so let's
do this and then this will be in this
will serve what you may have jumped
ahead and did yeah I can't help it you
know I know I
know okay uh so you only want the the
new the new truth okay the new truths
every day is a new chance to make
history good great things come to me
just focus on who I need to be all right
so let's slow that one down yeah so we
want to in the just kind of this just
focus it's like we we want that is an
opportunity to declare that right it's
like I am focused on who I need to be
what's the next one people want to be a
part of something that matters they will
help if I ask yeah just so wait let's
slow down okay yeah so are you going to
be asking for
help yeah yeah so Read that read that
whole both of those lines again people
want to be a part of something that
matters okay that's good now what's the
next one they will help if I ask yeah
the the negative thought there was
people won't help me so it's like it
could be you know people help me when I
ask it could be I ask for help like what
what's the what's the one that feels
more powerful to you I ask for help and
people respond I ask for help and you
know
um what what what one resonates with
you is it more like the asking that was
the issue or is it like the you know the
knowing that people help when you ask
probably both yeah so maybe it's like I
ask for help and people ask when I help
when I people help when I
ask does that make sense like a
declaration like you're a way of being
is you have a listening now just imagine
you walk into a new room and you're
listening for the room is I ask for help
and people help when I ask there's a
whole new way of being there's a whole
new openness to that when you're
listening for that when you're seeing
that when you're being that does that
make sense yeah yeah no okay more than
makes sense it feels right yeah good
that's even better the heart not the
head okay just focus on who we need to
be so we did that uh all that matters is
that I care yep it's never been about me
and my story and perspective I don't
know where I was going with that oh what
do you what do you want to say here
though like what's the like if it's if
it's never about you like what do you
want to say here what is the real thing
behind that it was my story and
perspective help people there it is that
that's I just like trying to read what I
wrote so just write that my story you
don't need it's never about me it's like
my story and perspective help people
yeah now time out the the ones that are
repeated you're just going to cross out
right we're going to we get them handled
like the I am who I need to be replaced
just be who you need to be and then if
they're repeated you don't need them
again you can cross them out okay I'm
sure yeah I that's why I call them
unpaid invoices because some of them we
we already paid off perfect I just need
to give them something to mobilize
around yeah so we want to make that
definitive not you see you got this word
Justin there right so so I give
people blank to mobilize around yeah
what is the blank I give yeah yeah ideas
um yeah I like that uh yeah I get I hear
you to Mobile so it's like I give I like
that either one I like both I give
people ideas to mobilize around I give
people a movement to mobilize around see
CU when you're talking about 30 that
might be in line with your 35 million
you're giving people a movement you know
whatever resonates with you yeah okay
which one feels better I put movement I
put movement yeah yeah like that now I
want you to see something when people
ask me who I am I I could give them the
4 minute 32 second Version Y or I could
sometimes like you'll be out and they'll
be like hey what do you do I give I give
people a movement to mobilize around
right like now they're relating to you a
whole like wow oh I'm looking for a
movement yeah see and this is how you
create in the world by you first
creating yourself yeah so yeah I am I am
Shakespeare in the flesh yeah Walt
Disney Nike Google now who's going to be
the medii family and stand up and let me
create more or do you want to
marginalize me till I'm out of my
moment I love it answer sway okay uh
where are we
here uh boldness is a choice I am bold
and boldness and is a
choice okay is that my fingertips and I
have access to it whenever I want so
what is it that you have access to
boldness it was part of boldness I
didn't okay so I wrote boldness is a
choice it's at my fingertips and I have
access to it whenever I want yeah so it
could be like I am bold okay so we
change it to I am bold and boldness is a
choice yeah the second sentence is it's
at my fingertips and I have access to it
whenever I want yeah I have access to it
whenever I want humans are good they're
just in a lot of pain you may want to
just like humans are good you know what
I mean the just in a lot of
pain you're going to have a listening
always for pain but it's like if humans
are good even in the pain you're
listening for the humanness okay for
goodness I like it every day is a new
chance to change someone's life love it
and that's it everything else is a
repeat fantastic great work so what we
want to do is we want to
create like a document okay but before
so for instance I I may have showed you
the in my room uh in my house I got a
calligraphy version of my document and
my wife has one the first things we see
when we have in the morning is our
created life document if you ask my wife
who who I am she knows my whole document
you ask me who she is you know matter of
fact one of the did I ever share that
one of the things I listen to she has a
way better voice than I do um and I'm
telling you this because this is the
next part of your homework um so the
first thing I listen to in the morning
is my voice saying my documents but I'm
going to give you some homework but for
my birthday I got this version you are
Lov can you hear that you are the Divine
that's her that's your wife everything
way way better voice right now I hear
that like my document I've had clients
create documents like this they put up
in their wall where they where they have
it in their house about who they are in
their document so what you want to do is
the first thing we're going to do is
you're going to write your document now
you're going to take it off the number
order but you're going to just write it
each morning like a morning routine now
you may have like I inspired you with
the you know with my created life and
you may have added some things that's
all good you want to take that and if
you want to have believe and I am in the
mix of those two that's okay that's CU
that's your word that's your world the
belief world like the belief um movement
so what you want to do is for the next
days each morning you're just going to
write your
document you're just going to write I am
the you know I am every humans are good
you're just going to write it does that
make sense yeah after seven days don't
go longer than seven days you're going
to be able to know that what you're
going to do is rearrange it so it makes
sense like in your brain so the brain
goes by patterns so for instance you
know I put together uh I'm the greatest
father for my children and I embody love
presence patience kindness and joy and I
talk about my children and love in in
like one section right so you may
rearrange it it doesn't have to be the
order it's in but after s days you want
to be have the arrangement final of like
this is how I say it this is the order
does that make sense MH so that's
practice number one seven days y write
it so I'm basically like copying I'm not
writing it like from my brain I'm no
looking at it and writing it down and
then seeing what what feels right and
what doesn't yep after seven days you'll
keep looking at it but you'll you'll
write the same thing over for the next
for for at least 30 by 30 you'll
memorize it you know what I mean so
that's that's the first practice okay
that's the first practice the second
practice is you're going to say it out
loud just out loud to yourself walking
down you know you do your walks with the
um weighted vest you're going to you're
going to say it out loud three times a
day so the the 30 days I'm writing it
down because I'm gonna do it you know
I'm 30 days is writing it down for 30
days after the 30 days is saying it out
loud three times a day no during the 30
days you're also saying it out loud out
three times a day is that part of the
seven or this is after the
seven this is part of the seven in the
beginning it'll be mixed up yeah we
we're just getting the brain ready the
patterns to associate with this so three
times a day saying it out loud for 30
days but and then the first seven I'm
also writing it out and then the next 23
I'm still writing it out you still
writing it but now you're writing it in
the order that you're going to keep the
first seven is just to figure out and it
might not take seven it could take two
or one knowing you and you say this is
the order I'm I'm sticking with and you
do it the only reason to figure out the
order is you you may like I say stuff
about my wife in one section I you know
and the Brain will remember it like that
so it doesn't need to be seven days it
it could be one day and you say you know
what this is this I like how this feels
I'm just going with it and you're going
to write it for 30 days you're going to
say it out loud for your second practice
three times times a day Okay the third
practice is you're going to pick one
line so give me one line in in in what
you shared today like great things come
to me great things come to me so what
you're going to do is each day you're
going to pick one line which I call your
daily vitamin okay so great things come
to me now you're not going to go up to
PE you may say great things comeing to
me but all you want to do is use those
words in your language right
um you may say to your wife oh man that
was uh that was great I I love when you
come to me right like you you mix up the
the the the sentence and you just use
that language in your language
throughout the day when you cook great
things come to me great things happen
like you know you just use some of the
words and that's the daily vitamin when
I call my clients no matter where they
are before a game whether it's you know
before a big meeting I could call them
and say what's your daily V vitamin and
the and the clients who go like this
Evan take off always are on it the
clients who I call and they may be like
uh uh uh I'm like now they still go up
but it's not accelerated so you want to
commit to like just having this front of
mine as like this is my daily M vitamin
okay okay now are you a righty yes okay
so once you finalize the draft
somewhere within the 30 days when you're
writing it you're going to choose one
day and you're going to write it with
your left hand in the middle of the 30
days yeah anywhere in the middle like
anything I've asked you to do I've done
with clients clients have sent me oh I
believe you so for instance I could go
back to my left
hand and it came out better than I
thought so if you look it like I wrote
it with my left hand better than what my
right hand looks like dude yeah yeah it
look no it's probably better than my
right hand I write like a doctor over my
right hand so we want to pick one day
and the reason why we do that is when
you write with the left hand it accesses
the right part of the brain when you're
writing with the right like we want to
access different parts creativity
analytics all right that's that's your
practices uh now a bonus practice is
something I do that I like I I recorded
my statement and I listen to it before I
get out of bed so before I get out of
bed the first thing I listen to is my
document of who I am I am love I'm the
Divine Light That illuminates every room
I enter I'm a miracle I create Miracles
with ease and Grace I hear that that's
the first thing I feed in my GPS okay
that's that's a bonus um practice you
call that something I call it my created
life but no the thing in the morning I
can't help put it like that's calling up
for some branding right like your the
whatever the thing is that needs to be
brand did something like okay I'll I'll
shut up I'm listening I'm reing well you
got to give me well that's your let's do
that as a bonus assignment you tell me
what that needs to be called and we'll
go with that all right so record it it's
helpful there's a there's an app that
I'll share with you Offline that you can
you can go in you can put your um put it
in and it it has like the the brain
waves on it it has music in the
background so if you if I'm working out
sometimes I'll put that on as well and
it plays your your plays your
declaration all right and then the last
the last one is you want to create a
touchstone something in your office
something in your home like you know
clients have created this I've had
people do like um glass displays I've
had people in their home have put it on
their basketball court all kinds of
stuff y so somewhere where you see it
every day and then finally so that's
about five practices the last practice
practice is is a lifelong commitment and
practice to it so you want to look for
you show up at one of those masterminds
you're in or you're in the airport and
people like who are you why are these
video guys uh uh following you and you
say oh you want to know who I am or you
want to know my name and then take the
time to share with them and you could
share the whole version you could share
a 10c version a 30 second version get in
the practices you know I create
movements you know and and whatever your
document says and and that's a lifelong
commitment so those are your
practices I like it yeah so repeat them
back to me so I know we got them okay so
in my words I put homework create a
document and putting on the wall uh I
put create a version create a recording
of me saying it I also put a bonus of
also think about having AI Steve Jobs or
Kanye say it to me too yeah write it
every day for seven days after seven
days rework it to the order that I want
to keep do the whole thing thing for 30
days three times a day read it out loud
starting right away pick one line daily
as a vitamin use it in my language every
day in middle of the 30 days write the
whole thing with my left hand bonus
practice before getting out of bed
listen to the document Touch Tone uh
door frame I put door frames because
when I go through a door frame I hit the
door frame and it it's a reminder of
like great things under me and when I
Ted lasso style yeah so but whatever so
I both door frames but and printed sheet
so printing out the final version of it
uh and lifelong commitment and practice
for it you got it brother okay do you
want to hear what I what I like did as
my Declaration of Independence and I'd
love any suggestions on language or
tweaks um this was my in the moment uh
rush to get something out so I'd love to
see what you think
so my Declaration of Independence I
believe that great things come to me I
believe that every day is a new chance
to make history and stop me like say
pause if there's anything that comes up
uh I believe that every day is a new
chance to make history every day is a
new chance to change somebody's life
every day is a new chance to make myself
proud every day is a new chance to lead
with love I believe that boldness is a
choice it's always at my fingertips and
I have access to it whenever I want I
believe that I'm one video away from
doubling my audience I believe that
people are good and if they're not
spreading love it's because they're in a
lot of pain so I don't if we want to
edit that one because it bring and a
little of the negative but correct um so
you want to cut that now just pause for
a minute when you went to the go back to
the boldness one for a minute I believe
I believe that boldness is a choice it's
always at my fingertips and I have
access to it whenever I want so as you
go through it I like some of the Bel
because it's the language in which you
use however like what we did over there
we want to incorporate into this one too
so it's not like you get rid of all the
beliefs but it's like I am boldness and
and blank is a more powerful kind of
definitive uh statement of it so you
want to see the only thing I would say
is you want to see what what we did over
here Incorporated here and then leave
the ones that believe um just resonate
with you because I know that that's part
of who you are it's like how you created
a movement so but there are some of
these that you may look at I am instead
of I believe yeah I add that my homework
now swap I believe to I am as much as
possible yeah and and I wouldn't totally
get rid of believe because I think that
that's part of the core of kind of what
makes you you're the guy who goes into
the rooms and you bring belief that's
that's your thing so we want to stay
aligned with that because that that just
is a is a great frequency you're on with
that and we there's a way to kind of
like I am is it more of a declarative I
am bold is is way powerful uh more
powerful than I believe people are bold
you know I believe I'm bold sure yeah
okay so as I go through if you hear like
an an easy one yeah let me know we'll
we'll swap it uh I'll just make a note
there
okay so then it was I believe I'm one
video away from doubling my audience I
am one video away from that's it I am
one video away from doubling my audience
great I believe that people are good and
if they're not spreading love it's
because they're in a lot of
pain I believe that people are good I
believe it's important to be the light
in the dark I am the light in the dark
there you go well done yeah as my my
lady says she's you know she's
Australian but has lived in Scotland
most of her life was she says well well
spotted well spotted thank you for
noticing I believe that people want to
be more
positive there are heroes out there
doing great work Shine the Light on them
and organize for
kindness I don't have have all the
answers but can spark the mind that will
solve the
problem that was in reference to the two
pack quote it was like I don't uh I
think it was I don't have all the an but
I'll spark the spark the brain and I
just change it to spark the mind that
will solve the problem yeah so it's like
I spark the mind that solves the
problem okay you could keep I don't have
all the answers if you want it's just
like I hear you I hear you again I was
like fumbling through this and I
appreciate the like we surgically
cutting to make it actually work you
know um I believe that people want to be
a part of something that
matters I believe that people want to
help me and I just need to ask I would
just say people want to help me oh
remember we we Chang it is like I ask
for help and people help me when I ask
or something like that uh I ask for help
and people help when I ask yeah more
declaration okay I'll swap that out yeah
when people compliment me I receive the
gift and thank them for noticing yep
perfect I compliment others and
positively reinforce the behaviors
they're working on I'm a champion of
their future self I love that one that
one I'm a champion of their future self
that's
like that one hit me really good that is
one of your superpowers like you are a
champion for people so you've been a
champion for me well you're you're thank
you for noticing and you're a champion
too brother I love it I believe that
every problem can be solved and that
modeling success is the fastest path I
think that's more
like every problem can be solved yeah I
think it's kind of forcing the I believe
this is a good thing it's like you'll
know like um energetically where the
belief you feel like that is something
that like you know is is is in line with
you so I'm just I'm just taking a stab
of what it Where where it feels for me
so um like I said we want to keep some
of them and we don't need all of them my
story and my perspective help people I'm
in a category of one and focus my
efforts on what I can uniquely do so
let's take those sentences separately
let's go with the first sentence again
my story and my perspective help people
that's it good what's the next one I'm
in a category of one and focus my
efforts on what I can uniquely do yeah
I'm in a category of one good yep and
focus my efforts on what I can uniquely
do I focus my then I would do new
sentence I focus my efforts on okay so
I'm in a category of one period I focus
my efforts on what I can uniquely do
yeah let's
go uh I think in business models my
enthusiasm penetrates to toughest souls
and I pour belief into the person in
front of me yep I love that love it I
feel great things are coming for you
too I do things I care about doing I'm
willing to destroy anything that isn't
excellent in my life my brain loves
solving problems so I choose more noble
problems and higher quality questions so
I can get to work on the
answers that can be reworked to be a
little more power that feels like more a
little clunky yeah yeah i' we work that
and maybe it's like one or two
definitive statements in that okay and
then all I need to do is focus on who I
need to be and then I had a whole bunch
of B statements but I don't know if you
want so all I need to do is focus or
just I need to focus or I focus I focus
on who I be or who I need to be I am
blank yeah I focus on who I who I need
to be or focus on Who I Am with more the
the clarity yeah of who I am or who I be
whatever either one of who I be who I be
I focus on who I am okay then I'll
switch all these out so uh ooh it
doesn't okay let me read this to you so
you can you can see where I went with it
uh be loving be enthusiastic be caring
be bold be ambitious be playful be
helpful be kind be brave be courageous
be me and then believe so I ended off
with I ended with believe so switch it
to the I am then it screws up the ending
but whatever I'm fine with that
too or I focus on who I be and then it
all works see be is like we don't want
be to be like one day it's like I am is
like in the now okay okay so I focus on
who I am I am loving okay that's fine I
could just end with believe too whatever
I am and still believe yeah I am believe
why not I am me yeah cool those could
all be I am statements
okay great all right I acknowledge you
brother great work thank you for
noticing you got it anything else I can
help you with today I think that's great
I got I got some homework to dive in and
start doing and uh I'll report back I
don't know I don't know what kind of a
accountability of reporting you want but
uh I'm doing it I'll be doing the work
yep well you'll get a checkin with me
one day out of the blue I'm going say
What vitamin uh did you take today and
uh you you'll be able to let me know and
over this month like what you'll do is I
this is a practice I've done I do every
day you know now 30 days is a good start
n you know between 30 and 66 it usually
becomes really ingrained as a habit and
then what'll happen is I like doing it
for 30 because within 30 you're going to
get your own Rhythm you have great
morning routines already so you you're
going to know how this is going to fit
in you'll fit some or all of it in your
morning routine moving forward it's not
something you do for 30 days and stop
you definitely want to like I say it
three times out loud a day still every
day I still got a a vitamin this is just
to get the Rhythm for you and then you
choose which of them that you continue
to keep
doing yeah if you text me and I I read
the message and it's what's your vitamin
and there's hesitation I'm in trouble
that's right I'm gonna call you out on
it and and this is a lifelong process
it's like for me people ask like how do
you show up and how you so present and
Powerful it's it's a creative way of
being it's a practice I'm this is what I
feed my GPS every single day so when I
I'm going we're going in Pennsylvania
and my son has a basketball tournament
so we're leaving soon I already know
who's going to be at the gym when we get
there I there's no guessing I know that
like if I get on the train and it's sold
out or something and we can't get on the
train there you won't see a new guy
acting out crazy there you'll see the
guy who I create myself to be in my
document so that's the power of this
work and then eventually what what
you'll notice of is those low grade
thoughts that used to pop up they'll pop
up and then initially through this work
you'll just replace them but eventually
what happens is they're gone so for
instance I'll give you an
example simple it's like I you know we
travel a lot I'm in I'm in flight so
back in the day there was always stuff
that happened at the airport flight
cancellations right and and initially I
had to rewire my thought of like okay
how can I make this a good thing then I
created it is like every time something
happens in an airport my first thought
there's no low grade thoughts at all
anymore my first thought is this is
going to be
fun this is going to be fun and when I
come from that place like I fly every
two weeks to Arizona as you know to see
my coach every two weeks over the last
year and a half there's been six flight
cancellations guess how many sessions
I've missed zero cuz my my my default is
this is going to be fun I get a chance
to create and I end up creating and
making sure I'm where I need need to be
so that's going to be the process first
you'll notice them you'll replace them
and then eventually you're going to call
me and you going be like two things yo
that thought isn't even there anymore
Devon wow like it's it's disappeared and
then two there's going to be people who
you run into who are going to share with
you hey EV man you are a movement maker
like they're going to share part of your
document without you even saying it
because it's just who you who you step
in and flood the room with who you're
being so that's that's what's gonna
occur guaranteed what's wild and this is
just the you know the the vibration
we're playing at right now uh I was
going to say hey thank you man before we
wrap tell us about what you do at the
airport because I think my audience
would really Vibe with that and you just
kind of let it out anyway so it's
great synchronicity is
happening that's it and I also do my
famous candy drop at the airport so
wherever I I go I get the candy for the
flight attendants for the pilots and and
uh always in service and and
appreciation for people man it goes a
long way and it's always fun in the
airports for me you've been picking up
Instagram game I love I love seeing you
walk into the stores and buying figuring
out which candy you're gonna drop off
for the the pilots and the anyway it's
great thank you man I got some homework
to do uh I'll I'll add that to the end
of this video but before I let you go
what uh people want to find you they've
enjoyed the trilogy where they going to
learn more about your world oh man just
uh just my name Devin bison.com go there
check out the game changer experience we
have the live version we have the online
version we got a membership Community
it's it's extraordinary it's the the
most transformational weekend on the
planet so uh just go to Devon bison.com
I love it I've got some work to do thank
you brother thanks brother take care
okay so I have some homework to do my
first step is I'm going to fix up my
Declaration of Independence
there's some other things I want to
incorporate in there and and also
switching up into more I am more
declarative statements now that I
actually understand the assignment and
then I've got 30 days of homework to do
I'm taking you along the journey okay so
it is early morning day one the key to
staying consistent on anything at least
for me is to put it in my calendar so I
have put doing this in my calendar I set
up my spot here at the this is the the
boardroom table in the office I have a
book dedicated to making this happen and
it's time to get to work let's
go so one of the things that Devon
talked about was doing a daily vitamin
right it's like what is one thing that
you want to remind yourself of daily
that comes from your Declaration of
Independence so I'm trying to think how
do I how am I going to remember this how
I going to remember it and keep it top
of mind not just in the moment in the
morning but throughout the entire day
that was his idea to be able to practice
it and use those words throughout the
day and so the first sentence is uh has
a box around it so that just that's my
sentence for the day and that was great
things come to me but it doesn't feel
like enough cuz I'm going to go have my
day I'm going to go do a bunch of things
I'm going to forget I'm not carrying
this book around with me so then I was
thinking but what what can I do to make
it more consistent do I write it on my
hand you know I could do that but that's
not very hey to have ink in my hand
every day um but then what I came up
with was sticky notes so I got these
sticky notes a while ago that uh have
the logo on it but I'm going to I'm
going to take this and put on the back
of my phone because what do we do every
day we use our I'm holding my phone
right now we use the phone every day and
so part of my plan for the next 30 days
to stay consistent and remember what the
vitamin the daily vitamin is that I need
to
remember is to write it on a sticky note
and then stick this on the back of my
phone so every time I pick up my phone
for whatever bam there it is it sounds
like it's going to work I'm going to
give it a
[Music]
shot okay today's day five my day has
exploded on me uh I have not done my my
habit yet I had a urgent call this
morning with a young entrepreneur who
was facing an issue and so he wanted
feedback so I agreed to help him and
that was an hour and I just got off uh a
zoom call with one of the most
recognizable athletes of Our
Generation uh and he wants to do more
YouTube stuff so we just spent two hours
with him which is great all all great
things but what it means is I haven't
done what I committed to doing and so
some days you're uh sometimes you're on
point and some days you're not the most
important thing is you just keep going
so it is now almost 4:00 I haven't eaten
yet and before I do that I'm going to
make sure that I get my day five
exercise done so I can be consistent
with the person who I said that I was
going to
be so today is day seven and what uh
Devin told me within the seven days I
need to do one day with my left
hand so it takes me about eight or nine
minutes to do the whole thing with my
right hand and today is leftand day so
we'll see how long this one takes me
here we
[Music]
go so it took me 133 minutes to write
this you can kind of read the day seven
and then my Declaration of Independence
it just kind of it just self-destructed
so normally takes me 8 n minutes this
took me 13 minutes to write and my
handwriting is okay I mean it's not it's
not it's legible right great things Happ
day one great things happen to be day
two you know day three you can still
read it great things come to me great
things come to me day four great things
come to me day five today that day was a
little rough but you can still read it
day six great things come to me then day
seven but I'm getting my homework
done
[Music]
all right I'm here with the man Deon
banderson we're here in Arizona I am on
day 21 you give me guys a 30-day
challenge I've been doing it every day
brighten down the manifesto my
Declaration of Independence it this
morning hotel room yesterday on the
airplane we're doing it every single day
what are you noticing it it's I'm uh I'm
getting there faster yeah I'm memorizing
some of the things yeah uh I'm I'm often
putting on some music to go with it we
got uh Jay-Z uh history you know that
song yeah I love it nobody people don't
know history I love history it's a great
song so I had that like looping in the
background just getting the Vibes going
but I had a little wrinkle to it okay A
little little little tiny little bonus
talk to me so if you look at that oh
here if if you look at if you go back to
the other side of my phone I go around
the other side and see what's on the
back of the
phone well he does it I am a champion of
their future self okay so you gave me
this challenge of the daily vitamin yep
and so what I did was I got a sticky
note and I put the daily message on the
back of my phone every day it changes
every day cuz the vitamin changes every
day I take a line from the thing from
The Credo and I put it there on the back
so anytime I pick up my phone I've got
it there there on the back is a reminder
what's the what's a daily vitamin well
well can I say something let let me just
tell you about this guy you I I text you
the other day and say you're the
ultimate student and you're you're a
master because the only difference
between the master and the student is
the master knows that he's always a
student so the way you're taking this on
is like some of my greatest clients in
the world have taking it on and you are
right up there with the best so I
acknowledge you for your commitment and
I love this thing you got in the back of
your phone thank you for noticing yeah
you got it okay now listen before we
wrap I got a special gift for you uh we
got I got some we got some P pull out
that first pull up pull up pull pull
that first one off pull this off pull
that
off oh my God that's his logo we got
some Deon bison custom sticky
notes my
man made my day right here whether
whether that's for you or for clients or
whatever it's probably a little big
depends on how big the phone is people
but but if you wanted to implement it or
or give it as a gift to some clients or
whatever it's like okay now they're
thinking about you with their daily
vitamin every day as well I appreciate
I'm I'm going to put my daily vitamin on
today I'm going join you and then this
will be good with clients okay there you
go man it's the man right here I still
got nine more days I'm still on my
hustle let's go
baby
okay so that is 30 of 30 days complete I
journaled and did my Declaration of
Independence through one of the most
busy times of my year uh I was away for
what 4 days for a big event and I came
back right into my Mastermind group
slept terribly almost the whole time for
a bunch of reasons but every day still
got up still did did my process some of
the times it was at night because first
thing in the morning I was I had to rush
out but I got it done every single day
and I didn't quite memorize it but I got
close and what I found was the more I
memorized the faster I wanted to go uh
my brain was going faster than my hand
could write uh and so I knew it was
coming and my handwriting if you look at
the the notes my handwriting got worse
and worse and worse and I was posted on
Instagram and people were making fun of
me for my messy handwriting it's cuz my
brain was going faster than my hand
could actually write um which is why
when I'm taking notes in general and I'm
thinking about my next ideas uh if I'm
going fast and to go on the computer cuz
my my handwriting cannot keep up with
the way my brain is going but I'm
excited I think the next step then is to
turn it into an audio recording um that
way I can go just as fast when I go on
my morning walk one of the things I do
every morning is I go for a walk and I
usually pop in one of the videos on my
own channel but I can start with this as
well and see what other changes I might
want to make to it but super appreciated
of Devon for the advice and the help and
the love and if you want to watch the
last time he pushed me oneon-one you can
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there the mind is like
a GPS it's a computer it's someone wakes
up has a cup of coffee they break the
cup of coffee and they usually say I'm
going to have a bad day